This episode of DNews is brought to you by
the U.S. Air Force.
A satellite landed a probe on a COMET today,
but it was launched 10 years ago.
Why did it take so long to get there?
The comet 67P/Churyumov-Gerasimenko is heading
into the inner solar system on its trip around
the sun.
67P flies around the sun and then out past
Jupiter every 6.45 years.
It was discovered in 1969, and selected for
the Rosetta mission in the early 2000s.
Rosetta's plan is to learn about the structure
and behavior of comets, but Rosetta was launched
in 2004, and 67P is still out past Mars…
It’s, at most, a year to get to Mars…
so why launch it so early?
Because gravity.
When a rocket reaches space, it has to escape
Earth's gravity: the escape velocity from
Earth's surface is 11.2 km/s -- Mach 33.
Yeah, it's fast.
Once in space, Rosetta will have to travel
at least that fast to begin its massive, parabolic
orbit on the way to catch a comet.
The thing is, even at 11.2 km/s it needs more
power! 67P is traveling at 37.5 km/s!
As the mass of the fuel increases on Earth,
it is exponentially more difficult to lift
a rocket to escape velocity…
So, the most fuel-efficient solution to accelerate
to that speed, as of now, is to perform gravity
assist maneuvers once in space.
To fling a craft around a planet and take
advantage of its gravity.
So you're flying toward Earth, and gravity
is pulling you down, you're speeding up!!
You get closer, and closer, and then ZOOM
PAST THE PLANET at astronomical speeds!
YAY!
But then, the same gravity is pulling… pulling…
pulling… slowing you down...
Like a biker going downhill and then back
up a hill of the same size!
The net change at the end of the day would
be zero!!
But, there's more to it than just the craft
and the gravity.
There's the movement of the whole planet.
The flinging of a craft around a massive celestial
body at JUST the right angle, speeds up the
craft by stealing a bit of energy from the
planet.
For example, when Voyager 2 was flung toward
Saturn in 1979, Jupiter SLOWED by 10 to the
negative 24th km/s... but Voyager GAINED 10
km/s!
A HUGE gain for Voyager, a tiny imperceptible
loss for Jupiter.
We call it a slingshot.
Rosetta left Earth in 2004, on a regular orbit
until it encountered Earth again almost EXACTLY
one year later.
Using Earth's gravity, Rosetta flung itself
around Earth and headed for Mars.
In early 2007, Mars' gravity slapped it on
again, on another path toward Earth, where
our gravity gave it a good smack later in
the same year.
Finally, after a MUCH longer orbit and third
Earth flyby in 2009…
It settled into giant orbit which brought
us to November of 2014…
When it FINALLY caught up with 67P.
These gravity assists took a long time, but
allowed the craft to accelerate to 55,000
km/hour, using only the gravity of planets
and a bit of fuel to make tiny course corrections.
It's not the most direct solution, but it's
efficient, and allowed it to fly past a few
asteroids on the way.
Now, thanks to the mission team, Rosetta is
orbiting a body with a gravitational pull
several hundred thousand times weaker than
on Earth.
It's moving at about 1 m/s relative to the
asteroid, or at the speed of walk.
In the end, Rosetta stole energy from two
planets and flung itself around the sun five
times in the last ten years, but now, thanks
to all that physics and LOTS of math, we landed
on a comet this morning for the first time
ever in human history.
Stories like this make me think, damn, trying
to land a spacecraft on a moving comet seems
impossible.
But somehow science is making it happen.
You know who else is good at achieving the
impossible?
The brave men and women in the United States
Air Force!
Whether it’s overcoming poverty to become
a nurse and officer or becoming the first
female Thunderbird pilot, these Airmen are
doing what others once thought was impossible.
So, a big shout out to the U.S. Air Force
for supporting DNews.
To learn more about Rosetta and the Mission
click here to see that handsome devil talk
about it, or you can go into the description
and check out DiscoveryNews.com, they're covering
the CRAP out of it.